hey gang get a monster announcement
before we get to the show
uncle hank and kippy are making a list
we're checking it twice
we're going to be coming to your town so
you better be nice we're hitting the
road baby
ru garbage is going on the road doing it
live
coming at you we're going to be in
raleigh good night's nashville zany's
indianapolis helium and cleveland
hilarities get your tickets they should
be available now on the club's website
can't wait to see it's going to be some
stand up it's going to be some live ayg
we're going to be taking questions from
the audience you get to ask us questions
we're gonna be asking you questions
it's gonna be a hoot baby limited
capacity social
socially distant so get your tickets
asap it's gonna be very fun
come and see us peace welcome to another
exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is
ru garbage it's a show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we found out
they grew up classy or
just a big old piece of trash oh yeah
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day
beautiful sun's out buns out baby down
here
aunt tooty's basement 70 degrees where
we're at
uh it's nice but not for me because i
went right from covet to [ __ ] chafing
season
real quick and the gold bond ain't
cutting it yeah
and i got bad news for you about hoodie
st paddy's day is coming up she's
throwing a party here
we got to get some of this stuff out all
right five bucks a cup anybody wants to
come
and don't steal any of the equipment my
co-host is coming
next to me those get longer and longer
and less and less of a joke i think
every week ah he hates the updates but
you kids love them so we're gonna keep
doing it
kevin james ryan everybody hey gang
happy to be here thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and you
already know what those numbers
are they trudeau [ __ ] roof baby thank
you guys
and then also patreon.com by the time
you hear this we're [ __ ]
cooking at patreon.com you get uh bonus
episodes of ayg
you get episodes of hard feeling which
is the [ __ ] money maker man
which is just me and foley hanging out
chopping it up kind of me calling him
fat you calling me bald
it's the new zendaya everybody wants a
piece of it it's a good time and then
also
every month with our top tier patrons we
do a live stream where you ask us
questions we ask you questions we play
ayg with you guys it's a good time get
involved baby
thank you so much and gang how about a
nice round of applause for our
producer extraordinaire the guy that
makes it all happen we've got a new lens
right now
little inside baseball so we're looking
a little sharp give it up for t-bone
toby mcmullen yeah t-bone when [ __ ]
empty my bank account on a lens
holy took a look and when i don't see
the difference i can't tell
yeah follow's always good after to
reassure you after a big purchase ah i
don't get it
i don't get it currently no invoices are
being taken but i will tell you what
boys beautiful day outside sunshine we
got the vaccine i'm kissing babies i'm
licking flagpoles i don't give a [ __ ]
let's go it's not too shabby we're
excited and we could not be more excited
our incredibly special guest back with
us today
this is a family episode we're doing the
patreon questions
we got a little company we got a little
star power
we love her you love her give it up for
our good friend
carly thank you guys for aquilina
me happy to be here thanks so much for
coming excited
i can't get the burger king thing out of
my head right now it's stitched
it's like 80s burger king you look like
you worked at a summer camp or something
i didn't realize until i saw my
reflection in the doors of the subway
i'm like i'm literally wearing the
burger king uniform that is it
you could be in the you could if it was
the 80s you could be in that commercial
oh my god and you're in the commercial
and they walk in and i'm standing there
what do you want
we said this on your episode and we're
not kissing your ass it's just it's just
the fact we love you
and and this is just the truth of it and
i think one of the good elements that
you bring to the show
is your cool eye your cool classiness to
decipher the garbage
i like that let's not with a little bit
of trash
you are a long
[Applause]
you sent us a video of you being like
these are the tomato jars i reuse like
you say i forgot about that did i tell
you about the one that's a little
ceramic one it's a little french
custard yogurt okay it's in uh whole
foods has it
it's like a little pot it's fantastic oh
i know which one you were talking about
the one where john stamos is on the
commercial
i think okay it's a french yogurt yes
that's exactly right and it's
like i got a clay pot yeah yeah yeah ooh
that's fancy
it's literal trash it's a pot it's a
clay pot it's so classy the main one
that you had that everybody has
my mom has thousands of them is the
stony field yogurt yeah
i don't think i've ever had stony field
yogurt you got the but i've been eating
meatballs out of their containers
for 20 years i don't know who eats the
[ __ ] yogurt and then all of a sudden
the meatballs are there i know
it's so crazy like i had sent you guys a
video of me like i had just cleaned out
my dishwasher and
in my head i was like this is so garbage
but you got a dishwasher because it was
keeps going back and forth she's classy
she's trying i can't get a read on this
bro
i'm a mix i'm a mix so it was like yeah
old jelly jars and
apple juice containers money this is
what i do you make money
i feel like it's better for the
environment to keep them
no yes no you're responsible and they're
glass so guys
glass is nice there's nothing wrong
do you melt the will you melt the label
off like if it's a martinelli's apple
juice will you melt that off
um i'll peel it off i'll peel it off i
don't have any you know equipment just
to keep that
no you can't peel it off i mean i mean
nice because you could like put a little
uh
a succulent or something in that wow wow
oh okay i know what you're saying
okay you know what i'm more for you
grape juice
or chili it's bananas it's insane to me
i have mason jars no it's an old school
thing
i bought like mason jars yeah but it's
kind of like having mason jars
yeah it is [ __ ] trash people go a
mason jar is a nickel
a dime you know it's not like the it's
not like a [ __ ] clear mason jar is
150 bucks
oh no it's free it gets me all riled up
i go oh i can't wait to keep this jar
i buy stuff just to keep the jars and i
use all of them
i do use all of them for leftovers yeah
he doesn't have to prefer
like ingredients i cook every day i cook
everything so i literally ingredients
all you got something left over you put
in a little jar you got all the jars
in the fridge no i'm agreeing with you
he doesn't go for that sentimental you
drink soda out of them that's what you
use them for out of you you drink out of
old pasta
pasta jars shut up you're not [ __ ]
emeril over here putting like chickpeas
in them
we're drinking juice out of it this is
where i ferment my almonds
yeah get the [ __ ] out of it it's just
gatorade
no yes i drink out of classico tomato
jars but what you're saying is is more
of an elevated thing and it's
it's there's a sentimental nostalgia to
it again it's the same
he doesn't get that i guess but it's the
same thing you guys are doing but it is
garbage
it is garbage oh no 100 i told you guys
it was garbage i made a whole video yeah
she's not fighting that she's you're
also one of
one of the comics that will just send us
stuff like quite regularly we have like
an ongoing thing which is like what
about these
i'm like oh guys i have a great idea
like i'm like you're like
producer i love it the best one you ever
sent me was uh
shaq what you put shorts jack shoes
i remember those kids oh man if you were
rocking shack shoes it was a tough look
they were nice
they were nice sneakers they weren't
ugly they looked good but like you knew
that they were shack shoes yeah you know
they were a whole different vibe they
were only available at marshalls and tj
maxx right or like i think that he had
like a deal with like colds or
or something like that like sears me
yeah they weren't at like the foot
lockers and stuff
where you get normal shoes no
[Laughter]
next to the snickers i just saw some he
ended up making he ended up selling like
he sold like 50 million
yeah he said he did them like that
because he wanted everybody
to be able to tell everybody to be able
to to get them which is really nice and
that seems very shack to me shaq seems
like
such a nice guy he's seen that he seems
like the best celebrity ever
he was like partying at the raves and
stuff he was at like you know edm
concerts and stuff
i remember like uh i guess mtv or
somebody had a tour of his house and it
was like his
giant heart yeah do you remember that i
was like that's
hot yeah yeah yeah i remember i in that
i think it's his ex-wife
now but it was they showed his wife and
she was like six six but looked
like she was like tall but looked like a
child yeah yeah
yeah i saw him walking down the street
once it was very
where in new york over here yeah
somewhere over here many years ago i
know exactly you see him from a mile
away it's like
that's jack new york you've seen him
yeah
yeah 100 is that keith or sutherland
we'll get a little closer we'll think i
think it's keith or something right
there's no question are you saying keith
or something
kiefer what is it kiefer it's kiefer i
think you said key there a couple of
times
i let it slid once or twice but you
double down though
what are you [ __ ] dark you're gonna
die me out here we're broadcasting i
don't know you claim to be a man of the
stage
a man of film a movie buff and you're
saying keith herself
fellow hey keever good to meet you man
um on that shack tip real quick before
we get to the questions
[ __ ] regis over here on that jack tip
let me circle back
i love when you turn broadcaster it's
great i wanted to get back to it
i'm this because i've been i've been
shopping for sneakers okay
i'm real close to going skechers oh i
like sketchers
yeah yeah wait
this goes back to her storing you know
fair trade walnuts in a in a saucepan
you drinking milk out of it it's she
looks different
you're doing you got the same products
but you're doing different [ __ ]
it depends on the sketchers it depends
on the style of sketchers
gotcha but sometimes having the thing
that nobody else has and wearing the
thing that nobody else wears is what
makes it cool cause if you're wearing
the same stuff that everybody else wears
it's kind of like you're wearing you're
wearing them relatively ironic here
i'm wearing them for for bunion comfort
yeah i'm saying that's i'm almost there
i'm a couple years away from therapeutic
shoes i think yeah
you look like you should have a helmet
on most times
i gotta see the style of it i'll i'll
see if velcro right across right right
across
love a velcro how convenient no yeah
come on no we can't
yes don't encourage him he's already
going into the dark side i understand
i understand what kevin's saying and
because what he said before is true too
you're the only person i've ever seen
pull off a dale earnhardt shirt and look
cool oh
thank you thank you so much only person
yeah
if he i mean if he did it it would look
like he'd be like at teledagger or
something
right right like a true nascar yeah
you're doing like oh there's just a cool
person
yeah mustard on me i got some kid on a
leash get over
you sitting in the infield
all right gang this is a family episode
you guys are amazing carly thank you for
coming in
already so excited let's get to the
questions we have your patreon questions
yeah guys so as you know when you sign
up for patreon we will ask your garbage
question
on air with a guest or uh with just me
and foley uh it's a good time some of
the questions are [ __ ] home runs by
the way
and we just get so many requests this is
the other way to do it so when you join
patreon we'll ask ask your question
and we will get to all of them we have a
little bit of a backlog just cause so
many [ __ ] the fish are jumping on the
boat you know what i mean
do we there's a yeah there's a lot i
think it's just an ongoing thing
yeah i don't know why you get stuck on
this for some reason paint ourselves in
a positive light you're doing wait
yeah we're doing great and the patreon
successful that's why it's tough to get
to all the questions so quick i feel
like my parents are getting a divorce
right now
i wish we could divorce he always thinks
i'm coming at him but i really love him
i know of course you do you gotta i know
yeah no i know you do
you're just a lot uh sometimes he was
being so nice
and you were being stupid wait just now
oh you deal with them [ __ ] eight
hours ago
i really love you yeah yeah yeah of
course you but you're just a lot
let's take our jars and sketches and get
out of here
i don't know i just watched foley pull
the e-brake on the highway and i gotta
agree with kippy on this one
it's very tough to broadcast with him
sometimes because he's nuts
so like all of a sudden you're like oh
we're having fun and then he's like no
you're like oh [ __ ] i don't know what
happened
for the record i realized i shouldn't
have said it the second that i said it
yes
see he gets it he's like a dog he's got
to train him i know
[Laughter]
he's got to get me out from under the
table first though
i'm hissing at him he pees every time
the doorbell rings
no i love you big guy wow i just said
that on tape that's a lot there you go
okay
for comment for comedy purposes
[Laughter]
you're always just fun right you're
right you fun lee
you're the only person i've ever been at
the bar with and you were like quick
let everybody let's do sharp shark tank
pitches so then you just gotta get up
and
we're all [ __ ] bombed up and we'll
just improvise like hey sharks and she's
like
what's your revenue she really gets into
it do you have a patent is it pending is
that you know
right and then everybody that was
playing shark tank when you're drunk at
all
it's so much fun it was one of the
[ __ ] people because
everybody has a an invention that they
think that they're like this is my
brilliant idea if i had the means i
would be a billionaire
because this is my invention so it's fun
to like spring that on people when
you're out at a bar and have them okay
do your pitch i'm gonna be barbara
corcoran yeah
she does the commercials now for the hr
uh
software oh okay yeah i got a piece of
it too oh yeah sure
she's got a lot she's not doing that for
free yeah she's got a short house she's
got a commission
oh yeah what's your shark tank so uh i
can't tell anybody
yeah otherwise you know she could baby
get hers off the ground thousands
i'm like it's a back scratcher i got one
my my investment's a little low right
now so i'll tell it on their case
there's any any financiers out there
okay
uh tissues and toilet paper for men
thicker
bigger guys thicker okay yeah there's
like 19 brands
too every time i you know the little
pack of tissues i think they've
sponsored the show at some point
you know you know the little we've
explained to them that these exist
they're called man wipes dude wipes no
they're called missions
that's what they're called they called
me
no is that what you've come up with some
issues issues yeah i just picture you
blowing your nose and blowing holes
dude it's the worst he's in black and
white on the infomercial
hey our tissue is not thick enough for
you do you need a beach towel because
you're
huge in an animal i fall off the balcony
he's wrapped up in an extension cord for
some reason you blow someone off the
balcony
when you blow your nose
oh that's so good i feel like you can't
make thicker toilet paper though because
it
that's bad for you you know that's bad
for the the pipes that's why she's
barber
yeah that's why she's part of that
that's bad for you you're gonna have to
dig up your yard in a year aaron
brockovich over here take it easy
we're still in the mental phases i'm
thinking i'm still doing some
some research and development i'm
already filing suits hey hang on a
second
i'm crying every time i use a regular
tissue
the worst ones are the ones in the
little pack that my girlfriend always
yeah why
did you ever try to use one of those as
a napkin remember to get out of here
you're in the car you're like oh i got
barbecue sauce and they're like oh
here's this it's like
buddy they were always in somebody's
book bag
at the bottom that was last resort yeah
those tissues are like old
they're never new i don't think they
sell them anymore they're just still
left over from the 90s
and i always hated that smell whenever
somebody smells like that i'm always
always like what
like tissue you don't think tissue has a
smell
what is crazy you're joking
what do you mean you've never smelled
somebody that smells like tissues
what she's legitimate shut up what are
you tasting
toby i can't breathe
what do you mean that's gotta be top
five dumbest [ __ ] you've ever seen
[Laughter]
sullivan carly you're
what are you talking
a fresh pack of tissue smells dude no
wonder you think tissues need
improvement
you think they smell no they kind of
smell good but they smell like tissues
like you know like a new book when you
open a new book
i think you're using books to blow your
nose
come on oh god you've never heard that
oh she smells like tissues
like somebody smells like an old lady
they smell like tissues no
i've never heard that estee lauder
softballs yes okay
oh my gosh i haven't laughed
i can't believe you guys don't know what
i'm talking about i literally have no
idea what you're talking about
like not even being like ah maybe i can
get there i literally have no clue
you're saying that tissues don't have
you've never smelled tissues that that
like tissue-y smell
not that been never been like oh i
recognize it on a human
at some point oh yeah he said i eat when
people smell it
i can't believe i don't know i don't
know what's going on this is a reason
this is an outrage i'm crying maybe you
just gotta really maybe you got a good
nose maybe you got a good nose and
you're smelling stuff that i'm not
smelling the smell of tissues i think is
a common thing around the world
right in call in yeah you heard it here
first folks i can't
uh any tissues i'm like do i have
boogers now because i was just gonna
start
laughing okay gang i don't know about
you but i have better things to do with
my day than stand in the post office
oh yeah now i happen to not but normal
people have better things to do with
their time
um that's why we got stamps.com for you
yeah baby the big time
so check it out we're recommending
stamps.com when you're mailing or
shipping anything
because you can do it online stamps.com
allows you to mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer can send letters you can send
packages
you pay a lot less with discounted rates
from ups
and the usps you know what i'm saying
with stamps.com
you get the service of the post office
and ups
all in one place not to mention what's
got
some nice big discounts on mailing and
shipping rates
oh yeah guys it's that it's really easy
to use
i am a fan a big fan of it uh simply
whatever computer you have you can use
you can use to send out and print
official us postage
24 7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
it any size
it don't matter as long as you got a
computer a connection and a printer
it's easy peasy baby we use it to send
out our merch
it's very good i highly recommend it
with stamps.com you get discounts up to
40
off the post office 62 off ups shipping
rates
not to mention stamps.com is a fraction
of the cost of those expensive posted
meters
they send you a package too super easy
stamps
sams.com is a no-brainer saving you time
and money it's no wonder a million small
businesses
already use stamps.com we got a lot of
small business
uh owners out there if you if you don't
already use stamps.com and get involved
stop wasting time by going to the post
office go to stamps.com instead
uh there's no risk and with our promo
code garbage
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus
plus free postage and a digital scale
there's no long-term commitment you can
stick and move baby i know how you do
uh just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in our code garbage at
stamps.com promo code garbage
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
boy are we having a hoot of a time over
there on the old stereo
oh yeah uncle hank and kippy are
together every week sometimes it's
thursday sometimes it's fridays
sometimes it's saturdays
the way you could know that is if you
follow us on the stereo app
you can see when we have our upcoming
event yeah guys it's a lot of fun we do
it every week it's like
a kind of the after party after the show
q a you get to ask
uh your garbage questions live on the
stream right there your voice goes up
live
listeners baby hot and fresh ready to go
uh me and big man are there every week
we're having a good time use the link in
the description
of this episode it's www.stereo.com
kevinryan or slash h foley either one
works we get to wet our beaks a little
bit
and you guys get to uh have a fun way to
interact with us in the show it's a good
time
get involved now back to the show
when i use those they stink and i think
that we could have
thicker ones more quilted more like a
paper towel
for for bigger guys okay okay
patent it call barbara call barbara i
mean work eight million dollars
i'm asking for 10 million dollars for
three percent of my credit card right
contingent appointment really use the
word contingency
upon me getting a patent yeah and some
of that chili the other guy was trying
to sell you
[Laughter]
all right let's do this here i'm sorry
um all right this is uh again patreon
questions this
i don't this one's just this one threw
me through a loop i don't know if
there's right or wrong or garbage or not
this is from claire do you call it a
knife and fork or fork a knife
fork a knife oh i don't think so i think
it's a knife and fork
what do you think fully i think it's a
knife and a fork knife fork and knife
sounds like neanderthals and knives yeah
i disagree i disagree with that
but i always assume that anything i did
as a kid or my parents did
would be the garbage sure and i can
remember
i think a fork and a knife is the is the
classy way to say it
because when i think of a knife and a
fork i always remember my mother saying
it
not in a nice way it was always use a
knife and a fork
like a human being yeah you know what i
mean
it was trashy interesting see i wouldn't
i would never
in a million years think of this as
something to decipher
because i don't think i've ever even
thought about it it's an interesting one
well if somebody says cutlery then you
know they got a little bit more
silverware if somebody says silverware
i'm like all right
i don't i didn't know can i get some
silverware right
yeah i mean come on yeah was there i
would never call it that
was there whether it was trashy or
whether it was good was there a set of
silverware
in either of your homes as kids that was
like for company no
not for company but if we were good
silver if we were eating in the dining
room
and people were coming over like the
prop like you know in the west wing of
the house
uh we would we had there was sterling
silver
rarely got broken out yeah no we got we
had the we had the
the knives and the forks and the spoons
that had the wooden handle
wow i mean that was that's tough yeah
that was i mean wait
i know the plastic i don't think i know
and then they have
they were like beige and they had little
silver dots
in them yeah anytime i went over to
someone's house they gave me one of
those it was a bad look
it was those things never the planes are
going to be like plastic
and they're like melted melted in the
dishwasher yeah yeah
we had nice steak knives like small ones
for like first yeah they
would still have them we bought them at
cut go and like that thing still it's
like 50 years old
she still breaks the box it's in the
cardboard box like the
it's all tattered like it's a christmas
tree
yeah yeah she's like keep the box we
gotta put it back in for sure yeah for
sure we still have a ginsu knife and it
still would it's still regularly used in
our house still with the little fork at
the top
cut through a nail or a shoe or whatever
yeah
cut through a nail they sell it on tv
right i think foley's parents were big
tv people i don't know if i
i don't know if i appreciate the way you
asked me that question you were like
they sell it on tv right
and if somebody has whatever invention
and i'll look them up and i'll buy
their stuff like i have a lot of things
from shark tank wow
and if i guess oh no my best one
is called uh it's not a snuggie it's a
comfy
you have one how luxurious
what's a company oh my god it's so
comfortable it's a blanket that's a
sweatshirt
oh i've seen it yeah it's huge it comes
in like one size it's like down to the
floor on me
and it's literally like a uh shearling
kind of i don't know what to call it
it's definitely not a cherry cloth it's
like the lining of an ugg boot
right it's like the lining of a dog boot
on the inside and the outside is like
velvety and it has a hood and a pocket
i mean it's just oh my god it's so warm
and comfy
that's the best shark tank convention
and i think they probably made like a
billion dollars because it's so good
they sell it at like the pharmacy too
that's awesome you know it's bad if it's
not if
a uh look all right and they lock it up
yeah it's a lot
like who's still watching can i get the
perfume
can you come unlock the cabinet oh god
yeah
i'm trying to get my hands on some
english leather here let's see right
it's they always lock that up in the
electronics it's like dude no one's
stealing the cd player
right right or like no one's stealing
the six-pack of vhs's
right right i was in a walgreens
yesterday that had the deodorant locked
up
that's a nice part of town i guess right
and they lock up the
dish pods too isn't that crazy the dish
pods and the deodorant yeah like the
tide pods the laundry pods
too jesus i don't know why maybe because
they they maybe cost a lot of money
people steal them
i don't know i don't maybe that's
something you can easily get in and just
take a handful yeah oh
yeah that makes you feel real yeah i'll
do that
it makes you feel real trashy when you
have to call the guy over he's unlocking
it like a [ __ ] safety deposit
oh right i had to do that i had to do
that for a charger at rite aid or
something
over the weekend in philly because i
forgot to charge her and he's like what
one do you need oh my god
he's like i asked a girl like can you
open this for me she goes yeah well i
can't but i can get somebody i'm like oh
great she's like just wait over there
standing there like a [ __ ] schmidt
right you're saying until security comes
over right and they
they're miserable because they have to
do that for people all day they're like
oh another person needs this just
let it all i mean just honestly get a
better security
it's system that hard like get a better
alarm yeah you know what else really
sucks so if you need something behind
the counter that you're not sure what it
is and like so you got to wait in line
to be like and they're like uh you don't
have anything to buy it you're like well
can i see that
right like this one that god pharmacy is
a little stressful
because there's always a line of people
if you're in the city there's always
always a line yeah yeah
self-checkout big self-checkout yeah i
i don't it's a lot of pressure i'd
rather somebody else what are you
auditioning to work there it's a yes
here's the thing that's how you feel i'm
like i feel like i always end up having
to ring the bell and then somebody's
coming over and i feel like an idiot
i always feel like an idiot and i'm like
i'm getting what like you know
one thing i'm getting toilet paper and
it i have it's like a surprise
now you know i get it you like it i love
it
why was the cashier at the grocery store
oh so you're like i'm really living the
glory days
you know what you're doing you're like i
got a banana yeah
tomatoes 40 88. yeah you give yourself a
discount
oh yeah i i not swipe some things yeah
oh yeah you got it at that point if
at that point i'm working for you yes
exactly
i'm gonna take some bananas if i'm
checking myself out for sure you do
you're stealing from the grocery store
what it's a big cookie
they they base like they base like one
percent of the [ __ ] you know shortage
every month they know what to listen i
know they go in the office and look at
the books
see what's available my wife pushes it a
little too fast she can sees a little
she's got sticky fingers
see that's why that's why that guy's
circling like the [ __ ] warden around
there
because of bozo's like you yeah i'm
always feeling like i'm still
have me do your job and i won't steal
yeah exactly get more
technology that's why you love it so
much
no i do feel like i feel like i'm the
pro coming in like hey guy don't worry
about me i know what i'm doing
yeah i got it i got experience and
especially when i go somewhere
and they don't do it in new york really
because there's typically a bag or
whatever but like in like a suburban
store or whatever you go like you could
like bag your own oh when you like flip
the stuff off i have
i'm like so like but like if you're at a
cashier and she's doing it they slide it
down to you yeah
it's like i paint my masterpiece it's
like get out of my way
give me the broccoli give me this and
like wow yeah and they always go oh do
you want to work here and i get off
i get i get off on it so i'm like oh do
you have another
no i'm busy yeah i'm busy i got a
podcast you know it's a thing but
i used to work i used to do it pull out
your bagger union card
i showed in my apron acme philadelphia
99. shout out to newtown pennsylvania
are you kevin ryan yes ma'am i am
a legend i've only heard about you i'm
outside gathering cards
they ride they they ride you out on
carts like a little parade
i'm on the rascal producer that was
always big as a bat it was somebody left
the rascal outside you got to drive it
back in oh yeah that was big for me
oh yeah that's exciting like driving a
car before you can you know what i mean
i forgot about the grocery store rascal
do they still have those or i'm chips i
hope so
i'm gonna need one in a couple of weeks
polly's gonna get a rascal and some
[ __ ] velcro shoes
uh my head hurts from laughing okay
let's get serious this is uh
this because this is an italian thing as
well but my mom just did it or
growing up did your furniture have slip
covers on it no no
but that's a big attack that's a big
italian grandma what's a slip cover like
a plastic
furniture cover and can i interject here
on something that was on patreon
that's what i brought it up oh okay so
um
just for the listener that's not on the
old patreon
kevin has a kevin's mom has a short
house she just got new car she just got
new
couch couches okay it's down the shore
okay okay
it's a beach house okay so picture like
a quilt
but kind of like you know cut out cut
out for the arms and the bat like so
it's like not like oh nice okay
it's like you know people are doing
those tortillas now where they're
slicing it and they're bending it yeah
yeah yeah picture something like that
but that
on the okay nice seashells all that kind
of like a sea horse on it because she
doesn't want to ruin the couch
yes but here's the thing he's saying
that it's garbage i'm not lucky
i think it's tacky but i get that
there's always there's like at any given
point there's like seven kids that are
coming from the beach
that's it right there of course i get it
conversation conversation over right
there if it wasn't down the beach
yes it would be garbage did she did she
make an effort to make it not look
garbage with the seashells and the nice
blue it looks like that it looks all
right
it looks all right but it's just yeah i
don't know because let me tell you what
i'm saying outside of a
outside of a vacation home
but i will say there's something like
when you get new furniture you're like
oh my god this has to last me so long i
have to
like take as best care of this as i
possibly can
you know so maybe she's just like
preparing because she knows it's going
to get destroyed
yeah yeah and she'll be thankful that
she had the cover when she sees how
destroyed the cover gets
exactly i know i go down there i'm down
there for the weekend and those are you
ain't coming
those little rug rats are running around
i sit on the couch and it's got sand or
all clank's got something
yeah you know what she's smart for doing
it yeah pick it up and just throw it in
the washing machine i know but when
you're laying on the couch it's like
falling off it's just right
what are we doing i want to [ __ ]
relax how about getting some work done
huh what are you doing
i did my chores get off my back come to
your room start playing music real loud
oh good stuff yeah i never had uh i
never had covers
no never had covers no i think my gran i
also think it's an age thing like
because now my mom's like a grandmom she
does it on the furniture
like i remember going to my grandmom's
house she had it yeah yeah i think that
must be what it is we had
um my couch tell me if you guys had this
too my couch and my parents house
growing up
matched the curtains and the kitchen
chairs and made the comforter
like it matched everything ran through
yeah it was like mom why would you
commit
like this like you can't ever change
your couch again and they never did
for like 20 years they had the same one
25 years probably
that's crazy this that that is that is
my mom did that
uh at one time in the 90s there was a
lot of tapestry was popping there was a
lot of like
peach and green in like the early 90s
there was nothing better when they that
one or two times in your life as a kid
where they redid something
oh well it was the new couch the new
carpet oh god
i remember when my parents got a new
carpet and it was like you couldn't walk
on it
it was like don't they kept the brown
paper down a little bit
yeah oh yeah keep the paper up hold up
appearances for a little while right
we would end up ruining everything it
didn't matter that's the thing when you
have kids everything
oh yeah the dog is gonna [ __ ] over there
or something spills everything spills
yeah but it's nice i think it is
psychotic though
i know people and it drives me crazy
when people don't take the the plastic
off of electronics
do you that person that you use the
cover on the right you do that you know
no no no
i don't like the clothes no i i don't
like that that's the best feeling ever
write off a new a new phone and you just
look at it for those three seconds
before you destroy it you're just like
oh
this is so clean that's garbage i love
that that's that's
the best christine it's never going to
be that good kind of look at it like
it's a diamond
yeah it's like perfect i can't believe
you know that not the tissue smell it
blows my mind
i can't believe that there's a tissue
smell i hope that i'm wrong i hope
somebody's like i know what tissue smell
like i want a description of the notes
of a tissue
i couldn't pick it out of a line a
little bit of vanilla yeah
um that's so funny my buddy growing up
and still
in both houses he he lived in a house
until we were like it was you know
i don't know 12 and they had built-in
couches
do you ever see those into
yeah yeah yeah it's cool but they uh
they were built like
into the ground in the floor like a
regular couch like a church piece
yeah kind of like a diner booth my buddy
had a diner booth in his kitchen growing
up it was pretty
oh that's cool was it like done the
right way or did they steal it from a
diner that was going on
or was it like hey we're going to
recreate yeah you're going to do what
you got to do you got to do it the grill
guy did live there for a little while
no they did it nice it was red it was
[ __ ] tight that's pretty good good
place to have when we had a party
was a good place to go a little pizza
party yeah yeah yeah that sounds fun
nothing wrong with it but i can't
imagine uh having a built-in couch
they're just there that's so crazy like
bought the house with it
i think they had them built and designed
but it was cool because it was like it
was a big couch so it was
it was maybe that's 20 feet long like
along the whole wall
so like when we were in like high school
we get all [ __ ] up and you would just
like sleep on it they could be like
i get that that was cool yeah there was
always that one family that did that
[ __ ] it was just a little bit different
the cookies
yeah it's the only place i've ever seen
it ever in my life
shout out to pat uh who's for sure
listening
um all right let's see let's see
do you use any of you this is from frank
uh do you use
any of your family's login credentials
for streaming services instead of paying
for your own
next question
who wrote that my mom what the [ __ ]
from henry's mother i don't know how i
get away with it but man
i got the whole package any app i
download it and i use their login from
there
from their comcast in philly spectrum
cable and i'm in new york i know it's
amazing
i'll be watching the sixers tonight
chilling wow i'll tell you the weather
in philly tomorrow morning if you want
i'll be watching action news i think i'm
all right thanks
i appreciate that i got an iphone uh
everybody does that i don't i have my
own accounts now my
which i feel like an adult use my
accounts that that's that that's okay
let's use my accounts and i actually use
my friends
hbo go there you go that's a good one to
like
i i was always like oh i don't know and
then i was watching something and she's
like just use my hbo go account and i
use that a lot
a lot because i have a projector i just
log in on my uh
laptop and it boom goes right on my wall
because i have like a big empty wall
that's your tv no i have a tv too i have
a tv in my living room but in my bedroom
i have a project is there a projector
like hall like it's in place or do you
have to set it up every time no it's in
place because i have one we have to set
up every time and it's
like on i have a fireplace and the
mantel i have the projector on there all
the time
how's the how's the uh the pictures look
at the driving it's beautiful yeah it's
like a drive-in movie
crisp yeah yeah it's it's a really nice
projector it's a good one
and i love to like just go on like hbo
and boom plug it in and then it's like a
movie
there you go it's very cool fun that's
not bad it's a nice little night out you
know yeah but that's the one that i use
i think the most and that's the one i
take for my friends hbo max is pretty
sweet
oh yeah not too shabby hbo max is nice i
don't know what's the i don't get i
don't understand
it's just every they it's just it's the
next upgrade of whatever
right hbo on demand was everything yeah
they're buying movies
yeah from my friend hbo max but they
have like the sopranos you can re-watch
the sopranos anytime you want
yeah but can you do that on regular hbo
no it doesn't exist anymore yeah that
doesn't exist
you have to pay for it it's warner bros
per episode
so it's all the ones oh you want to hear
something really really embarrassing
it does have turner classic movies
you're right yeah um
something really embarrassing about this
i and it's all coming back to me i
sat in on a uh
market research thing to make like 150
bucks
for this streaming service now that i
remember do you remember four hbo max it
was they were like well what if we
could combine these these and these
would that be something you were
interested in like a focus group that's
what's called a focus group because i
needed the money to be in a focus group
i needed the money i would love to be in
a focus group no i would do it for free
yeah well they give you
they give you like a 150 gift card which
i thought it was packed
i thought it was i needed the cash i
can't pay my [ __ ] rent with a gift
card you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i was in the fine print it was like an
american express or something oh that's
pretty nice no but i needed the cash i
ain't there for my help yeah you're not
there for fun like i would go for fun
yeah ooh yeah um try it's fun it's a
good time
they you feel really important oh yeah
that's why we're like would you like to
sit back like i don't know if i would
pay for them like you're a scientist a
jury
yeah exactly when you go to court
they're for 12 years surrounded by the
mirrors and they're all you know they're
back there watching
wow yeah it's a power trip you're like
i'll have another free water please
next thing you know elon musk walks in
kevin thank you for your help
i was in a bad spot this was not too
long ago by the way
how many have you done what's the
coolest one you've done it was all i
think
that might have been the only one i've
done and it was forced it was for that
and now i remember there was four hbo
like a new hbo
streaming service paired with movies wow
yeah yeah well there you go that's what
it is
i like that i passed on it in the focus
group well you passed on in real life
too i know apparently
i like the fact that we that we all
steal those from each other we share
those with each other it has like
it has like an 80s feel to it yeah yeah
and then it's cool
i don't know how we get away with it
though yeah i don't care i mean how do
they make
money how does netflix have all this
money to have million dollar budgets on
these shows well a lot of it is
yeah but they got cash coming in but
everybody can share their
account with four people yeah and i mean
these
netflix shows are big money you could
tell watching them i'm like this show
costs
like 10 million dollars sure well i'm
pretty sure they're running on a deficit
as well
they're definitely right over there like
they can just get rounds of [ __ ]
there's no way
oh whatever yeah yeah because i'm always
like there's no way they make that much
money
not yet i would assume right but i don't
know i don't know why they can't believe
that monthly cash flow is a lot i think
there's like 100 million users
in the u.s or something or globally
that's pretty good that's 900 million
dollars a month
i take it it's like 20 grand 150 to talk
about a streaming service i couldn't
afford
i'll take the 900 that's funny they pay
people 150 bucks to talk about billion
dollar deals
right right like why do you it was so
funny i literally thought i was a king
kevin what do you think my ginger reel
is flat thanks buddy
also what's even more embarrassing i
have a degree in marketing they were
like don't tell
anybody that because like then you
disqualify because you know the game oh
yeah so then i felt even cooler i'm like
i'm not even supposed right you're like
you're like a private investor i'm like
a double agent yeah yeah yeah both sides
again right
oh my god ran out to the mall and bought
a suit real quick i rented it came
back every product is designed by people
who are written
on their own oh dude for sure that's all
the feedback
dude and also hbo max has 3.7 million
3.7 million subscribers that's pretty
good what's that a month
that's a that's a like 10 bucks and
i thought it was 14. i thought it was
more than netflix probably it's probably
like 14. it's got to be 14
like and i will say i it's worth it
i think it's worth it i know i was in
the meeting
yeah i set the price i said one thing
over 15 bucks i ain't doing it
you turn into jay larson real quick
buddy we are i said don't go over 10 i
told him don't go over 10.
you're mad about it when you read about
it trying to get back into the focus
group
yeah oh man i wonder if they even do
those anymore
kovid oh probably not there's like
online ones you can do but you're like
for a nickel
right it's always bad when it's like
it's like it's like [ __ ]
it's the 27th of the month and i'm like
how can you make 500 bucks today right
i'm googling that
you've googled 500 bucks yeah man i've
been in some tight spots okay
just now we're starting to make a little
bit of cash and i gotta split it with
youtube bozos
you're reading soldier a fortune doing a
hit
[Laughter]
how do i make two grand today i gotta
fly to ecuador
all right moving on my personal finances
aren't a
topic of discussion have you ever sold
blood for money i've thought about it
yeah but it's only like 25 bucks i'm
like i can get 25 bucks
yeah or 50. i can get my hands i'm
playing bigger
i'm looking after bigger deals hbo kind
of stuff you know what i mean i thought
blood you donate
yeah they'll pay they could they'll pay
you for like it's like 20 bucks the
plasma is where the money's at
right or bone marrow yeah yeah you get a
couple hundo i hear blu-ray is pretty
popular too
oh my god that's so funny i have a
friend that her
she found out she's a sperm donor baby
and she has like
nine brothers and sisters that she found
holy [ __ ] yeah yeah
and and and wait this is so interesting
her
biological father is the season one
winner of survivor
richard yes no way shout out to rick she
should have her on your podcast she's
very cool that's banana yeah pretty
crazy right
he was like needed the money and was
like donating so much sperm and like
wow damn that's not bad you're fine
that's a nice little jackpot plus he was
a nudist too
he was like he was always yeah yeah yeah
always something going on shout out to
richard pretty cool
i forget his last name but i remember
him yeah yeah he was the first one you
always remember the first one at least
he's not a bozo you know what i mean
it'd be cool
i think he wants to find that find out
your dad's derek jeter or something like
that oh that would be cool
that i would like be looking for a
little could have sex with my dad or
something
uh all right let's see uh this is from
sean mack have you ever framed a poster
that's yes really yes well this brings
up i think the old
you know is it trashier to not frame it
wait right if you just stick more
thumbtacks in it like an animal
hold on what do we what are we talking
about we talking about high school
are we talking about that i think it's
an open-ended thing yeah
well i think now if you did it as an
adult now it wouldn't just be a poster
it would be like a print
right if you're going if you're going to
a poster shop
right getting a [ __ ] metallic around
are we talking like spencer
or gifts poster something framing cheap
i'll tell you that exactly
yeah exactly that's a hundo right there
yeah and there are some pretty cool
posters i guess i mean i'm not hating on
it
yeah i mean i did it i found a print of
i mean it's a poster
that's why i said yes i'm like i did
that yeah um and i found this really
cool like old vintage frame and i like
put it in there but it was like a print
of something that was in the
uh monica's apartment in friends and
that was like what was um the
like french poster that was behind her
tv or
like whatever it was art that was right
i can't pull it big friends guy though
oh love it love it
we have a vote he had the coolest
apartment we have a vote the guys wanted
it yeah yeah yeah
we got a vogue print that we think we're
pretty cool to have oh yeah yeah so
it's just a poster yeah it's just one of
those things it's real remember the
posters
the poster the shitty frames that were
plastic where you had to stick it
together
they never always [ __ ] came the
bottom always right yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] up my nirvana poster what's up
we have which we also did on the patreon
my wife found a fit
it's like the most insane thing that's
in our apartment
it's a it's a fish like chart of like
oh cool no it's bananas a fish chart
wait it's not cool you're saying
it's she it's cool in the sense that
like it's obscure
i could see like something fishes with
their names with their like their greek
name like a smallmouth
butterfly i'll see there you go yeah
yeah yeah i've seen that fish in
a seafood joint that's pretty classy i
think i think that's your new york city
one room apartment
it's not like i mean it's not it's not
like a [ __ ] marine theme we got going
on hey baldy let me get to see that
find it somebody in our building was
getting rid of it oh okay
yeah you don't have any attachment to it
if you don't like it you could chuck it
i've been wanting to chuck it but it's
it's the first thing you see
what kind of fish oh my god it's all
north american
freshwater fish i think you could be
like oh my god i bumped into it and the
frame broke
yeah that's pretty good so i threw it
out so i threw it all right i burned it
i apologized
we've been robbed they just took the
fish poster oh this is a shame
have you done something like that have
you ever sabotaged anything you didn't
want in the house
um there was um
well i was dating this guy i lived with
this guy and he
uh would wear the same hoodie every
single day and i made it disappear
really yeah that's a lame
and he had like four of the same one and
he wore it
every single day and my friends were
like does he wear it every day because
every time they saw him he was wearing
the same hoodie i want to know exactly
what you did he never i i
i donated it that's it one day grabbed
it yeah
because i would do the laundry so i was
like yeah
you got to go see him yeah now you don't
the back and forth is crazy like
to do that is is psycho it's garbage to
do it
but then but then you don't throw it out
you don't hate it that's close
you gotta donate you can't just throw it
i throw it out you throw out clothes i
do it with the intention to donate it
but
i just throw it out it's just like in
your trunk for like a year yeah and then
i just go what am i doing like
i see i always donate my wife donates or
you put it outside
somebody will take it yeah you put it
i've i've done that before like you just
put a bag of clothes outside somebody
takes it in three seconds
i always i'm leaving stuff outside my
apartment like little things
instead of hanging outside carly's
apartment really pick up some butterfly
photos so funny because my neighbor
always takes the stuff
really yeah the guy that lives next door
to me yeah
but you're working at burger king i'm
still waiting for mine to get ordered
it's like the booths at burger king
that's what it is like those old boots
separate
yes it's the orange it's like the orange
and yellow yeah that's
i'm in charge of who comes into the like
the playpen yeah
only two at a time on a swing oh those
filthy things that we used to
that were proper outside they burger
king did they ever have playstation they
were like outside they had outdoor they
had the outdoor ones
yeah you would get in there was like a
burger
with like a cage and you would like
climb into the burger and you'd be like
it was like a bun and a bun with like
whatever
and you'd be in the middle i remember it
was stainless steel and i remember being
oh my god
10 000 degrees in august oh yeah dude it
was like burning
i remember like ah i'm like this [ __ ] is
bananas
my mom's just like eating her [ __ ]
chicken tenders or whatever
oh my god that's so funny favorite
chicken tenders from any fast food place
was the old school
burger king chicken of course wow i
strongly disagree
i was never a burger king girl i was
always a mcdonald's girl oh yeah
every once in a while see everyone
aren't you sponsored by mcdonald's no
i think about it sometimes yeah
i was never a burger king gal that's why
i choose mcdonald's sometimes
shamrock shakes available from six to
ten
i grow i grew up like eating like as a
special treat you get mcdonald's yeah
but my i don't think we very very rarely
but that's not why i said that i
you talk too much about burger king oh i
love it
lose the hawaiian shirt donate it
um all right let's see here this one is
from jason do you this is just
animalistic do you use the same utensil
between
jars of peanut butter jelly butter honey
etcetera or whatever you do
yeah no no no no bran i i i'll use seven
knives or four out of it's making me
it's it's really freaking me out
terrible that and then also too which i
was thinking this weekend
crumbs in the butter is a tough look
after toast crumbs in the butter go over
to someone else's house i'm like i gotta
eat your crumbs
you know my crumbs i don't mind if i
gotta eat your dad's crumbs
this is right if you've got company you
gotta scoop out your crumbs
you gotta get you gotta at least cut a
slice out you know
first as a buffer you know but you
shouldn't be
i mean there's no way i the thought of
like having
the mix of some the peanut butter inside
the jelly jar
or the mustard inside the mayo oh my god
i think i know where the big man falls
on this one i see his face and i can
tell
what do you guys want to hear the truth
yeah nothing but the truth
i can't get away with it anymore um but
i would be just uh
a back and forth guy with the same thing
just can't get away with it anymore and
recently more recently i'd like to admit
i had a similar situation with some
cream cheese
where there was some crumbs in there and
i loved it it was like old pieces of
tortilla chip oh you put it on you
spread it to your chips and your cream
cheese i don't know what was going on
it was a little piece of a blue corn
tortilla chip was in the cream cheese
okay you don't use cream cheese and
salsa
no i use sour cream and salsa that's the
money i just go straight
sour cream and salsa mixed together yeah
it's good
the best that's good i just go straight
salsa i guess
you could also heat up a little regular
too
you can heat up a little brick or cream
cheese in the microwave and then pour
salsa on top and
it's nice interesting okay that seems
like something that would be in a
cookbook in like the 90s
but this is like fun parties you know
taco juice yeah yeah
taco dip or something uh this implies
that you were using just the chips
right out of the cheese the cream cheese
container yes i believe it
[Laughter]
i love cream cheese i love cream cheese
i love it yeah
it's so good big fan cream cheese and
bagel at a nice joint
and they have the nice the flavor to get
them with a fresh bagel and cream cheese
whoops a fresh bagel i i never go toast
that was just that was in the news or on
something that there i never debate
about that never toast
no never toast unless it's like a couple
it looks like a day or two old
then you could toast it put some butter
on it but no it's not like brooklyn
bagel or yeah if i go somewhere
ever and they say toasted it's always no
never
i'll tell you why kids that's crazy
never
i knew that i knew this is chicago this
is what chicago does to you guys
no i knew this was coming you're not no
it's you're you're
100 percent right now you guys are in
the minority before this turns into a
war just let me explain
america maybe but of new york no because
whatever they want to do yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i don't care i don't care what your
[ __ ] are eating lenders okay these
are fresh
new york bagels okay with the water
if it's fresh yeah if it's fresh you
wouldn't toast it
that's how good they are that's the
fresh you want the fruit but i know what
you're saying
but that's only when like carly said to
a degree
if you're going into a new if i we
brought you into a bagel shop in new
york
what are you gonna get you miss me and
then get to you and can they either
plain toast [ __ ] with cream cheese
no because then it's gonna slide right
out first of all oh
never had one then you're tasting the
toast not the bagel you're right
you're tasting you might as well be
toasting white bread sometimes hot cream
cheese can go real wrong right
slides right out yeah it's like a
terminator too because the
the perfect just grab it onto the car
it's got nice hands it's coming after
you yeah t-bone get out of here with
that
yeah yeah the perfect bagel is like a
lit it's fluffy inside
and just like the perfect consistency
outside why don't you toast that
yeah for as fat as i am and yeah i don't
mind a scoop
little scoop i love a scoop i don't mind
just screaming there's room for stuff in
there not a scoop i'm not a scoop guy
no that's bad scoop is good i always get
a scoop almost what about you
i don't do a lot of call to actions on
this i don't ask for a lot from the
listeners in the view
[ __ ] prove these idiots wrong you're
gonna be wrong t-bone you're gonna
if you don't there's no buddy at
home all right at whatever you know
amway you're [ __ ] safe
yeah you're getting your bagels from
yeah
if you're buying a six pack of bagels
toast that [ __ ] sure yes it's thomas
a bacon egg and cheese or a sausage egg
and cheese if you're a [ __ ]
gentleman you don't buy the combo in new
york if it was made that day
in new york at the bagel place you don't
toast it yeah i feel like people
like around the country they get their
bagels from dunkin donuts
yeah you toast the dumplings because
those people are talking
some of them aren't big dunkin stinks
they're not a sponsor are they no they
stink i like their
[ __ ] shirts yeah oh my god time to
make the donuts multifaceted
that's who carly is trying to make the
doughnuts that's it acting a method
um duncan in new york stinks they're all
dirty
they're all you go in no one knows
what's it's chaos oh i love
i i like duncan i like their hashtags oh
i mean they should sell those by the
dozens oh yeah not the six piece
right exactly you never get just one you
gotta get two uh they're like bitcoins
[ __ ] popping those good nights
you just you just like sparked something
in my brain that i don't mean to say on
the show for a while
what mcdonald's talking about it yeah
okay ten piece nugget five bucks three
piece
one dollar you get three of those or
it's a four piece one dollar you get
three of those three bucks 12 nuggets
three dollars two more nuggets you save
two bucks
it's unbelievable did toby just break
mcdonald's just hacked his head
geez push the dollar menu the manchurian
candidate over
you did here much math i know so much
more than i didn't do it give me a
number six
and call it a [ __ ] day that's right
yeah the stripped selects
you're just mad about you're just mad
about the bagels i'm so upset about
uh you're very wrong on that yeah you're
so is that a question
what the bagel i don't know how are we
talking about no we were talking about
we were talking about crumbs in the
cream cheese oh
ooh okay yeah crumbs in the butter um i
like it
this is a perfect segue this is from
anthony gonzalez shout out to aunt
anthony
uh is it garbage to lick the plastic
mcdonald's sauce holder to get every
drop
jesus yes right trash yeah yeah yeah
yeah use your [ __ ] fries look at that
gentlemen that's what fries are for
that's what
[Music]
like four sweet and sour sauces on one
thing fries
i scoop to me it's just i want to get
all the sauce yeah
to me it's just a vehicle yes yes
it's just getting from point a to point
b and the size the the fries or that
vehicle that is a print that is the
premier sauce
what the sweet tower i'm not a i'm a
barbecue guy barbecue straight up the
middle
nothing tastes like mcdonald's barbecue
isn't even like my top
two my top top two i mean that's a top
100
there's only three five yeah it's not
even my top one
well i used to rock as a kid i don't
think they do it anymore but they used
to give you
they'd give you [ __ ] uh mcnuggets
with straight honey
oh yeah they still do it they still do
it i've done it
yeah they give you a packet you guys
talking about nuggets i got a deal for
that
listen if you blink three times with a
guy he might hook you up
i used to love getting jacked up on that
mcdonald's honey
hell yeah very nice very lovely
conversation i love it see what else um
this uh did your dad our folks complain
about the did you have did your parents
ever go out of their way or will you to
get
cheaper gas like would you like you were
like oh the place down the you know
next town over has five cent cheaper gas
would your parents do that my parents i
think would do that because there was
like
on long island i feel like there's gas
stations like right across the street
from each other so you're kind of in the
middle of an intersection like i'm the
king
at that point like you don't know which
one you're going to you read them all
so yeah but i don't think they would go
out like to another town
but they would they had their eyes but
they had their options because they
all the gas stations were kind of
competitive that is long island's varied
there's four on everything a lot of gas
stations
yeah yeah yeah i don't know it's getting
a lot of there's a lot of [ __ ] exxons
and loot coils and [ __ ]
what's going on something something's
going on out well i've only been there a
handful of times
they like their fossil fuels out there
big natural gas island my mother
now this is this is a this is a
45-year mission that's ongoing
okay she can tell you right now you call
on the phone right now
she'll tell you to the to the one-tenth
of a cent
the price of gas within a 20-mile radius
good for her what wawa has what [ __ ]
this one has what luke oil is doing
you know two miles away wow and there'll
be
there'll be a rotation well if you pay
cash at deluca
you get 10 off or whatever oh yeah yeah
that's bananas
i'm so just i don't want to be
inconvenienced so even if it's like
this is a dollar more i'm like whatever
what's that what's it thirteen dollars
right those old
yeah i think that's a parent's thing to
do yeah that's a parent's thing to do
we're driving 20 minutes away to get gas
right when
two minutes away is it's you know ten
cents we're wasting five dollars in gas
to get to the other town yeah yeah yeah
do you have a car now do you drive no i
don't even have a driver's license oh my
god
no crazy have you ever driven i drove
when i was a teenager a few
for a couple months how do you and then
not have a license you just never really
expired and i never renewed it but i
don't have a state id
i have to renew it um soon
yeah what do you have a statement two
years
two years after the expiration yeah what
they give you two years to renew it
otherwise you have to take your road
test again but since i don't drive i
just never
do you have to take your test you know
you gotta go do it now no i gotta go do
it yeah yeah could you pass the test now
probably not because you're not thinking
about it probably not yeah i mean i
haven't driven since i was like 18 17 18
years old yeah jesus christ
what do you what do you travel well
passport yeah passport or do you have a
statement
we're going to go out to the ball oh i
don't have a state idea you're going to
get caught at the bar
your passport yeah international bar
hopper i mean it's so embarrassing it's
that's either why that's either like i'm
refined or i have a dui that's all that
means
that's literally you see a guy at the
bar like oh my god is my pizza
i got friends that roll with their
passport yeah and it ain't because
they're traveling
yeah oh my good man is this philadelphia
by any chance yeah
so scary though like going out without
with your passport because the the risk
of losing it and
carrying a baby oh yeah i've had to do
it before when my license expired when i
because i have a pennsylvania license
so it's expired and i've been up here
and i'm like i can't get down for a
couple weeks so i roll with my
passport and it's like you feel you're
never you have like drugs
yeah yeah yeah i'm like constantly
checking [ __ ] is it still
in there yeah it's better than a state
id man
embarrassing yeah uh any time i do
travel with like
uh travel internationally with a
passport i'm like
paranoid yeah i'll sit in my seat and
like i'll sit on my plane
and my my the seat on the plane i'll go
okay it's here i know it's here
it's in the top pouch of the bag and
then an hour later i'm like let me just
double check to make sure oh hi
panic i know having a passport on you is
so stressful
yeah it's so how old were you when you
got your passport this is a new question
because you were a very early episode
for the listener if you haven't gone
back and forth oh yeah
you were consumers like a very or even a
very early zoom
right you were very early yeah this was
it was probably like a year ago
yeah almost to the day yeah yeah yeah
maybe
one of our first eight episodes wow yeah
um
so this is a big one now is how old were
you when you got your i got a passport
when i was 16.
pretty good pretty good but i was going
on a cruise
family cruise no with like um
kind of like high school oh like a yeah
yeah
yeah jeez i know it's grimy i mean what
else are you going to do in high school
what are you going to do
i mean where are you going to go not go
on a cruise you don't want to cruise
just like go to florida should have gone
to florida yeah but on a boat you can't
get in trouble you're like on a boat
i got in trouble i got arrested on the
boat
[Laughter]
like place to lock you and then they and
then they um
interview you and i was lucky that i was
16 so i wasn't
able to like actually get in real real
yeah
i didn't even do anything i was just
like around when there was a fight
and then i got blamed even though i
didn't fight against girls fighting or
guys
why is fighting i just don't understand
rolling up to like a crime scene or like
a fight being like yeah oh no
i you know what i mean like lock her up
she clearly i know well i was like
these guys are bothering us i told them
to go away
they got mad and like got in my face and
then another guy got involved and like
defended me
and they fought and i got in trouble
and they got in trouble too he's a real
provocateur this one
what is this cruise is this a teenager
carnival cruise line but was it all
teenagers
no these guys were grown adults uh i
didn't yeah it was gross
how were kids allowed to go on a cruise
but there was no parents no
i didn't have my period
that like is the legal guardian of
everybody you like science it's crazy
she's probably [ __ ] she's probably
have four pinots deep
right she was catching yeah what mom's
gonna sign up for that's not going to
i felt so bad because it was like
imagine having to deal with that and
they didn't let me off the boat
the next day where like when we got to
like
[Laughter]
i always wanted to see south carolina
i always wanted to go to myrtle beach
that's where i went when i was in the
high school for college
myrtle beach wait on a cruise
myrtle beach was so cool it's so tragic
we went i went in high school then again
in college oh my god that's the
specificity of myrtle beach
for the muscles there was like a
makeshift mardi gras of like everybody
driving down you like hung beads out and
i remember
it was one of the funniest funniest
jokes shout out to my boy ryan jones
how did he was swirling the beats he
goes i'm running a deal two titties one
bead
and i was like that is the funniest
thing i've ever heard he goes a two for
one deal two titties one b
oh my god that's so funny that's garbage
but i didn't see any boobs the whole
time
as like a 17 year old hoping to see some
boobs in public i mean that's like
pretty much takes up your whole day
that was it we were playing boobs yeah i
was like writing lines to try to get
right i bought i spent like five grand
on beads
what the [ __ ] all right let's do want to
do more than we got to wrap it up free
amazon you couldn't get the deal yeah no
i had to like go into a store and buy
beads like a [ __ ] ass yeah a little
pervert
[Laughter]
what are you doing with these huh going
down the myrtle beach aren't you
guys i can't stop a little dirtbag
all right this one ten thousand beads
please there's a couple
uh this is a two a two parter based on
laundry
geez right uh two from two different
people do i need a calculator for this
do you how do what's your laundry
process now do you have in unit
washer dryer do you send it out there's
a washer and dryer in the basement of my
build i live in a brownstone there's a
washer and dryer in the basement i don't
go down there
no too sketchy i still get scared not
going down
yet no no there's two i'm i to me
that's not my space and i don't know
what's down there it's never going to be
light enough for me to go down there
it's always dark right
basements always have one light bulb in
the whole in the whole damn swinging
yeah
yeah
sweet it's like dim what i don't do it
no i agree but it's also never new york
cause you drop it off or have it
i drop it off yeah i drop it like a
dollar two yeah i drop off wow i'm
surprised you don't do it yourself
i know i used to when i lived in my last
apartment but this apartment i'm like
because my last apartment you had like
each floor had
a laundry room which was perfect nobody
was ever in there
yeah those are like college those are
nice people can hear you scream if you
get jammed up
you're not in the basement getting stuck
in that no i'm just saying
somebody can get you in the basement if
you're next to the incinerator or
whatever
oh yeah yeah yeah we're next to the
super's workshop that's a band
the candyman shows up to grab you but if
you're on the first floor if you're
you know if there's apartments next to
you she'll be all right yeah you'll be
yeah
i was getting you on the fourth floor
that was nice that was nice but i
since i moved no i just i go and drop
off
i don't want to go back and forth to the
laundromat and you're cool with what
fabric
what like what uh detergent they use all
stuff yeah go crazy
they don't shrink anything no really
most of my clothes are vintage i feel
like they're already shrunk if they were
gonna shrink they would have shrunk
gotcha you know yeah that's true i'm
surprised you don't have a unit in your
place i know that you don't do it a lot
of pl it's a a lot of don't do that
though because they flood and then it
ruins everybody's
anybody behind sure right i have my
first apartment that i moved into in new
york because my buddy owned it
and he was grandfathered and had a
washer and dryer so i was like oh this
is great and then i moved to
like a place where i had to take it
myself it's like this is animalistic
right i know
it's i i had a place in park slope that
had a washer and dryer years ago and i
was like this is the best yeah yeah
if you don't live in new york you have
no idea bro instead of throwing clothes
in the hamper i would throw it in the
washing machine yeah and then
every day do a little load because
they're cute they're like a bowl of
pasta
how cute is that do you have a a
dishwasher not to brag
oh you have one just got one of my doors
how nice is it oh it's a [ __ ]
game changer game changer changer yeah
um i look at like a i look at the dishes
like five minutes i'll be done this you
rinse it
um this one's from homer this is uh
based on the laundry this is from homer
rodriguez uh have you ever taken your
clothes to the laundromat in something
other than a laundry bag
like a trap like have you ever been in a
always a laundry bag always a laundry
bag
always a big you know what i use um
the tj matt you know when you go to tj
maxx you get those 99
like reusable big bags i have one in my
bag right now that's my like thing if i
cuz they carry so much
so i filmed putting stuff yeah and i
bring one at you know one
however often i go to the laundromat we
show up with an ikea if we're doing the
comforter it works
tell me about it those are you we got a
couple of those floating around here
yeah those are great
they carry so much yeah yeah they're
awesome i've had to do it one time in a
trash bag because i was like jammed i
don't know what happened to my bag
i think the laundry detergent spilled
all over my bag that's the worst or
something so i was like
so i put it in a laundry i put it in a
trash bag yeah i was just like hey
i'll buy if you sell along i'll buy one
off of you right but like
i wasn't going to walk here just with
like all of my clothes yeah in your
hands i had to put it in something
yeah let me ask is this wait i think i
understood what you said
you had laundered your head and spill in
your laundry bag i had to get rid of my
laundry bag for some reason i think
i recall that was the reason well don't
if you guys do do it yourselves
don't you wash the bag that you carry it
over there into
not every time no really no oh that
always goes right in
the bag goes in with the stuff what no
are you crazy i mean that's really nice
that you do that
that's not trashy that's actually what's
the bag made out of they're typically
not like a
no they're like nice laundry bags yeah
they buy one from the plate
yeah exactly yeah but it's like it's
like windbreaker material no you're
supposed to watch
yeah yeah yeah you're supposed to wash
why the [ __ ] would you put
the bag that had dirty clothes in it put
clean clothes
i mean there's not like poop and mud on
my clothes ah
here and plus by the way when they give
it back to you
that i'm saying this when they give it
to her looking at me like when they
i agree i think that that's great that
you do that i can't believe you do that
when they give it back to you it's in a
plastic bag
right sealed inside yeah so i'm saying
but the bag's still dirty i don't know i
mean you're very fancy
i can't do it you know that i'm not i
can't believe you guys don't do it i've
i don't even i've never never even
crossed
my mind if i use a laundry laundry bag i
would wash it every so
i wouldn't wash it every time i wouldn't
even think to wash it every day yeah i
mean that's like truly like very much
you have your [ __ ] together vibes
well i don't i do it just because i
don't want to what am i gonna do with
the bag while i'm waiting for the
laundry to change over
standing around like an [ __ ] yeah i
leave it on top of the washer or
whatever
right yeah you leave it on top not my
neighborhood
okay i don't know whatever um
yeah yeah not my neighborhood not
astoria that's what i get
nicest part of queens uh yeah it's more
laundry bag heist per year
uh astoria all right let's wrap it up
guys we gotta wrap it up we gotta wrap
up gang we love you
carly we love you such a fun one thank
you thank you for having me
what do you got cooking you got anything
coming up anything you want the folks to
know out there um
secret keepers club is my podcast and
you can follow me at carlie aquilino on
instagram twitter and fashiongirl42069
on tick tock
oh you went viral for something yeah i
went viral for uh
was it the king or something or the no
it was um
[Music]
the four seasons total landscaping
that's what it was that's what it was
i can't believe i didn't just know that
off the top of my head yeah four seasons
total
so funny yeah yeah there you have it
folks that's
my legacy i was doing santa for 10 years
i did one video my neighbor called me
hey i saw you i'm like oh my god i saw
you on tmz yeah i was like oh my
goodness
but that was funny that's very funny
kippy what do you got
guys as always please make sure you view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube
uh and then patreon.com for bonus
content i'm at kevinryan common on all
social media let's get those [ __ ]
numbers up you know what i mean
guys thank you so much we appreciate the
support y'all are the best yeah thank
you gang we love you
t-boned we love you we'll see you guys
next week peace
beautiful i don't think i can legally
let you guys
hit pause unless we talk about the
stereo app one more time
want to remind everybody fantastic app
doesn't matter whether you have an
iphone or an
android who cares i don't care you can
download it and you can sign up for free
yeah guys use the link in the
description if you're watching this if
you're listening to it the link
uh our promo link is in the description
it's either www.stereo.com
kevinryan or slash h foley sign up
get involved we're doing weekly shows
answering your questions
i'm having a couple of beers every time
we do it i am having fun i look forward
to it every week we'll see you there
peace